a lot of people are scared to grow on
social media because they think that
they have to show their face in order to
grow and make money but actually that's
not the case I know so many people who
are making money online who don't even
show their face they're making between
$10 to $20,000 a month without showing
their face so how do they do this so
there are two main ways the first way is
taking other people's content and making
compilations of it and actually
monetizing it this content is going to
go viral because they're taking the
content of an already established person
whose content has already gone viral so
it's aen method the second way is by
making top 10 trending videos on YouTube
and that's called YouTube automation but
it only works if you make trending
content it's a fantastic way to go viral
very quickly and once you go viral
you'll get approved for ad revenue and
then you start monetizing you can start
bringing in 5 to 10K a month and that's
only at the beginning